en itagüí un barrio de clase media
libanesa cristiana y uno de los más
afectados por la explosión del puerto de
agosto 2020 hasta ahora este barrio ha
sido feudo de las falanges libanesas y
también de las fuerzas libanesas
cristianas pero ahora los partidos
tradicionales compiten con nuevas caras
gente que ha salido de la sociedad civil
del descontento por la crisis económica
tan profunda que atraviesa este país los
partidos tradicionales por supuesto que
han hablado de ayudar a cambiar la
economía pero no han dicho nada sobre la
corrupción y el clientelismo político
vamos a ver qué opinan los libaneses y
qué futuro creen que tiene este país
soy una persona positiva y quedamos muy
pocos en el país que tenemos esperanza
las elecciones son buenas para el cambio
y nuestros políticos se han dado cuenta
que tienen que cambiar confío en que las
cosas van a ir mejor después de las
elecciones de ayer james clavell
vivimos una de las peores crisis
económicas del mundo no podemos seguir
así es demasiado
basada en animales vez no es un error no
votar porque de lo contrario será aún
peor ya les haría
con la crisis económica como mayor
preocupación los libaneses piden un
cambio más allá de un cambio democrático
lo que esperan es sanar su economía algo
que muchos han dejado de creer en sus
políticos tradicionales pero la
alternativa de los nuevos candidatos
también es complicado ya que son la
mayoría desconocidos y tampoco han
sabido dar alternativas para mejorar la
economía